so good evening everyone my name is
Kimberly Martin I'm the acting director
of the Herman Institute for the 2012 13
year and I am delighted to welcome you
to the opening event of our core project
for the year the theme of the project is
corruption and patronage and what we are
trying to do rather than simply describe
corruption and patronage is to think of
some interesting unique unexpected ways
of thinking about the problems of
corruption and patronage and I wanted to
just very briefly introduce the two
postdoctoral fellows who are working on
the project this year if they could each
stamp Jesse Dillon savage and Frederick
shoberg and so you'll be seeing them
throughout the year if you continue to
come to these events and the next event
that we have on the schedule will be on
October 30th at the same time but in a
different room I believe it'll be in low
library and for that event will be
having William Browder of Hermitage
capital speak about his experiences with
corruption and patronage in Russia and
for that event you will have to
pre-register and I believe the link with
the pre-registration will go up on the
Harriman Institute website and if you're
on the Harriman Institute mailing list
it'll come out to you within the next
day or two now it is my incredible
pleasure and delight to introduce the
panel that will be speaking to you this
evening first I'm just absolutely
delighted to welcome dr. Michael Klein
he is the professor at the Frankfurt
School of Finance and management in
Germany and a senior adjunct professor
at the School of Advanced International
Studies sites at Johns Hopkins he has
worked in many capacities at the World
Bank most recently as vice president for
financial and private-sector development
for the World Bank group as well as the
chief economist for the International
Finance Corporation before that he was
the chief economist of Royal Dutch Shell
Group from 1997 to 2000 and he headed
the unit for non-oecd economies at the
OECD Economics Department before that
also he has been active in Amnesty
International and served on its German
Board and the International Executive
Committee so in addition to his
incredible expertise in finance he all
has obviously a very strong interest in
human rights
he studied in Bonn New Haven and Paris
and he received his doctorate in
economics from Bhanu's bond University
in Germany we'll be having two
respondents to the presentation by
professor Klein on the academic side
first we'll have Timothy Frey our own
Timothy Frye who is on leave as the
director of the Harriman Institute Tim
Frye is the marshal Shulman professor of
post-soviet foreign policy at Columbia
in the political science department he
has published widely on political
economy questions that are related to
the entire post socialist political
space and currently in addition to his
appointment at Columbia and his work at
Columbia he is working at the Center for
the Study of institutions and
development at the higher economic
school in Moscow he's directing that
program with a grant from the Russian
government and then our second
respondent will be our own dr. Gail
Boyce key who has a PhD from Columbia
and is a Harriman alum and we are just
absolutely delighted to have the
opportunity to welcome Harriman alums to
participate in our events she is
currently a non-executive director with
extensive experience on the boards of
directors of banks in former Soviet
countries including Russia Ukraine and
Kazakhstan and on the advisory boards of
private equity funds and she also has
significant involvement in sustainable
finance initiatives including the
chairing the board of Russian micro and
small business bank kmb bank and has
done just a wide variety of work she
also published a book that came out of
her dissertation at Columbia called
banking in on small business
microfinance in contemporary Russia
published by Cornell University Press in
2007 and before doing all of this work
on these banking boards
she had an extensive banking career at
Chase Manhattan and at the European Bank
for Reconstruction and Development and
so we just have a wonderful panel and so
now let me turn it over to Professor
Klein
so thank you very much good evening and
I hope you will find evening interesting
kimberly has very nicely and very kindly
introduced us all and also very nicely
said this is about perspectives on
corruption so I don't know how the world
works either this is just a few
perspectives based on the work that I've
done as well as the art academic
endeavor at the moment in Somalia you
may know a process is underway to form a
new government a transition government
has been formed it's now supposed to go
over into a more permanent government
and what that means is that a bunch of
people who one might call or might
previously have called warlords or
otherwise roving bandits are now being
put together in a thing called
government and almost by definition they
are thereby given or the attempt is to
give them a monopoly about over
legitimate violence and so here are
people that are given monopoly powers
and to entice them as part of the effort
to entice them to to take these monopoly
powers they're also being promised
development aid and financial assistance
etc and those who are working with the
process have publicly said that they
know that if you hold out a bunch of
money and give monopoly power over
violence in a country that is currently
ranked last and the transparency
international corruption index is a
recipe for having some sort of
corruption going on and so you're almost
institutionalizing it in the process and
then the question is yeah is this bad or
is this acceptable this process of
trying to form a state out of
dysfunctional entities that are not very
nice and very good for the citizens is
that a bad thing or a good thing and I
don't know either Oh what
the right answer in this context is but
it seems to me that basically as you
move up the letter from economic hell
like in Somalia to something better
hopefully economic heaven you have to go
through a purgatory where things are
sometimes black and white or not black
and white where there are very very gray
and where lots of dilemmas arise and
compromises have to be made and you have
to find a way of having an attitude to
what what constitutes an acceptable
compromise and what does not with that
in mind and this goes to the title of
this I'll come up with a few
considerations that may be useful I
started my first long-term assignment in
World Bank Group on Nigeria in the early
middle 1980s and I got to read about mr.
morrow dqo Merrill dqo was Transport
Minister and secretary-general of the
ruling party under the democratic
government of xuxa gari that was in the
country between 79 and 83 and he this
was one of the first elected governments
after the Biafra war so everybody was
happy that democracy was taking some
root in Nigeria and the World Bank and
others also commented that Nigeria under
this and previous rulers was using its
oil wealth at least in part
intelligently to help construct roads
and schools and thereby helping develop
the country in a sensible way and not
just by having white elephants and
prestige projects and so Maruti coal is
still alive and just September 29th
since barely three weeks ago he was
interviewed by a newspaper today Lee
independent and amongst other things
made this remark about corruption
corruption corruption people talk about
corruption but the problem is this no
government has so far been able to
tackle corruption none
unfortunately when your people hear when
you hear people being taken to court for
corruption next time there are bailed
and they're off so this is
Rico's words who comes from the
democratic government who presided over
transport investments and who is now
called an elder statesman by this
newspaper when I her first heard about
Amaru deco was in the spring of 1984
there was a little article in the Moon
which had a blurb saying that a certain
Amaru dqo who had fled Nigeria
celebrating his first billion pound
sterling his British mansion and so next
thing everybody heard about are a bunch
of people heard and those who have the
internet now can look it up with all its
glory on July 4th in 1984 British
customs official I think it's Stansted
Airport found a crate wrongly labeled as
diplomatic baggage so some kind of
mistake of form in labeling and
diplomatic varnish they opened it and I
found Amaro Dickel ready to be shipped
to Nigeria ah because the then
government of general Hari who had
rousted the previous democratic
government on the 31st of December 1983
try to get the money back and get this
person who was accused of major
corruption as this as the man at the
centre of power and get him back to
Nigeria since when the Nigerian said
decoe Airlines a great way to fly this
all goes to say there are all these
confusing stories you hear one narrative
and it sounds good you hear another one
it's not so good your smoke screens and
puzzles and that's essential to any
corrupt system because yeah on the one
hand everybody in a corrupt system knows
so-and-so is corrupt but nobody has
really the real information to put this
together in a way that could stand up in
court and that's part of the essence of
the problem so how can we understand
these systems better and say something
halfway intelligent about how they might
change and where they might go and what
one might do so since 1995
well since the early 90s and with a
particular set of things happening in 95
more and more data have been collected
by people about corruption
now corruption is not readily observable
so collecting data is a difficult thing
so the most visible and best-known stuff
which came out for the first time in
1995 is transparency international's
index of corruption perceptions in the
same year a staffer at the IMF mr.
malroux wrote a famous paper or
well-known paper about how in
cross-country regressions in
cross-country statistical analysis
it seemed that more corruption went
together with a worse economic outcome
so corruption didn't seem to be so good
for economic growth at least that was
the prime interpretation of the work and
at the World Bank mr. James D Wolfensohn
became president and made corruption a
word that should be used in public
debate it's not that nobody had been
aware of corruption beforehand people
used to be aware of it talked about it
I'll give you some examples later on
about slightly more polite worse like
rent-seeking were used not only more
polite but sometimes more intelligent
because sometimes it's hard to
distinguish between what is waste and
what is corruption
what is stealing and what is waste and
rent-seeking is sort of a mix of both
more easily anyway be that as it may
from then on there has been a constant
effort to improve the datasets a new
kind of data try to drill down more and
more and at the World Bank for example
we put together a whole series of data
which now cover more than 125 countries
in a world on earth roughly three year
cycle of enterprise surveys where when
asked firms how they experience life
including what they think about what
kind of payments have to be made when
the tax officer comes or when the
customs guys come or when you want an
operating license etc and so the hope
was by drilling down we're getting more
and more to people who may have an
actual experience with corruption
get better data sets etc and now we have
a little bit of time to evaluate whether
that is really so and it's not terribly
clear well how much progress were really
making just one example we constructed
an index from these firm level surveys
for a hundred and seven developing
countries that ranked them on the depths
of corruption coming from these sir firm
level surveys and compared that for the
with the corruption perception index of
transparency international so there are
170 have 107 countries and I'll just
mention the examples of Russia and China
so on the CPI the corruption perception
index China came in I think this was
2010 at number 35 out of 107 so not bad
and Russia came in at number 93 out of
107 pretty bad when using this other
index China came in at 69 and Russia at
72 virtually undistinguishable so the
people who should know are saying
there's not much difference and the
people who are slightly more removed
from the corruption business say there's
a huge difference so we don't really
know or necessarily what is the truth
other cases have come out up since then
which cast doubt as to whether the
people who are creating perception index
indices the people the so-called experts
or observers for being asked how much
they really know so one of the best
known cases where you can say something
about that is Peru when under the
fujimori regime mr. Montesinos
corruption ring was blown up the scandal
that erupted led to a material shift in
the perception index of transparency
international so that says if people had
really known you know there shouldn't
have been a shift in the index but
apparently they didn't this is not
surprising and this is not to say that
these perception indices don't make any
sense and can't be used for something
but we just have to be
aware of how much reality and how much
meaning there is in each one of them and
so then what have we learned what can we
say we've learned from all these data
including data of individual scandals
where there were investigations or
judicial processes press reports about
actual amounts being stolen first
observation is when you compare the
amounts stolen through corruption to the
sales volumes to which they apply if you
like it's just a few percentage points
on average it's not a lot
so normally economists would say three
four or five percentage points of
indirect tax in an economy is actually a
quite efficient way of raising revenue
so why should raising three to five
percentage points or so off corrupt
money or money in corrupt ways raising
that in corrupt ways why should that be
so bad
this is a puzzle so the amount itself
cannot explain why corruption is so bad
it must be something else going on the
way in which this money is raised is the
big issue not the amount per se not
trying to justify the amounts I'm just
saying the amounts per se don't explain
it the second thing is it seems
plausible that countries that are
relatively rich in this world are
ostensibly not so corrupt that's what
comes out of perception indices that
seems to make sense from what one knows
and perceives etc and at the same time
that's become clear ever since that
article of mr. Morrow in 1995 that there
is actually no significant correlation
between corruption and growth rates so
the level of income is associated with
less corruption higher income less
corruption but the growth rates that our
countries are able to achieve on the way
to higher riches don't seem to be
correlated in any systematic way across
countries with the level of corruption
as measured by the data which with all
the problems that we have and so the
question is so this after two decades of
work on data to my mind is a
as a snapshot of what we have learned
from that exercise and so then people
are now calling some maybe there is
something about the types of corruptions
the nature of particular corrupt
enterprises that really should be at the
center of any investigation and before
going into the detail there
our first observation the big thing when
thinking about corruption is the rule
systems that are exist in a country it's
not the breaking of the rules the
corruption itself that is the prime
should be the prime focus I think of
analysis this is not to say corruption
is not important but when thinking about
it think about the rules for it to make
the point just a few examples when I
worked on Nigeria one day I sat on the
plane and next to me there was this
person male in the mid mid 30s and we
got to talk and the guy said I'm working
for a construction company of an
important country and I'm one of a
handful of people in who in Nigeria make
sure that for the construction projects
which this company has all over the
states of Nigeria all the right payments
are made to everybody and the way he
described it was that it was almost
clear so much for the fire chief so much
for the mayor so much for the police guy
etcetera so like a fee schedule and you
just had to know what it was
that's why you need intermediaries who
know that the rules and then he made
sure that happened and that's the way
they ran their their business then 20
years later or so I happen to work in a
World Bank on a thing called to doing
business project which measures official
regulations for various types of
policies that govern the business
environment one of them are being
business registration so this is about
how difficult is it to set up a small
firm in different countries and one day
we came to Greece this was before the
crisis and some parts of Greek
government say we have to do something
about this and most countries find it
attractive to make it easier for small
and medium enterprises to come into the
market it's politically popular you know
everything and
but not in Greece why so you learn after
not very long time that there are so
many process steps that you have to go
through to set up is very complicated
and at various of these steps fees have
to be paid so all legal there's no
corruption involved and the fees go all
of them most of I think it was all of
them into the pension front of the
lawyers in Greece so how can you change
this you know these are the people who
dominate Parliament these are the people
who dominate anything so what's the
difference between this Nigerian system
and that Greek system is two sets of
dysfunctional rules one is entirely
legal the other is entirely corrupt but
the outcome is hardly to be the material
consequence are not very different in
fact it could even be argued that the
Nigerian system was more stable than the
Greek system because a lot of these
informal rules in Nigeria are
extraordinarily stable whereas some of
the formal rules elsewhere can be
circumvented so it's not obvious that
there is a difference on that ground
second point is business about getting
about bad rules so the most detailed
work or some of the most detailed work
that some people at the World Bank and
researchers at Harvard have done on
business registration is to compare what
is officially required by law and
regulation to what actually happens in
practice measured by the enterprise
surveys comparing that to the doing
business project and I find that to make
a long story short after laborious work
across countries is that when the system
that is official is relatively simple
and efficient people sort of stick to
the law whereas when it gets complicated
people find ways around it sometimes
sometimes not answer is all there's no
more relation between what's on the
books and what's happening in practice
an example of that is in South auto in
Brazil we had for years a situation
where officially to set up a small
business you needed to wait for 150 days
until you went through all the
procedures that were required
and then when you talk to the Brazilians
as after a while officially yes but in
practice that will happen and how how do
you get around this well facilitators
know so well yeah so there we have the
answer so when we think about the role
corruption plays we have to refer back
to the rules to see whether what are the
rule systems how much how efficient are
there how much corruption do they and
dodging ously generate actually and look
at that as the primary issue and then
when we want to go further and look a
little bit at can we put more structure
to this question I mean it must be the
type of corruption that matters not the
amounts and it's the type of rules etc
then it's probably argue it is useful to
actually look at it from the point of
view of somebody who wants to be corrupt
so if you imagine for a second you know
you all leave your conscience at home
and you would like to run a corruption
record Oh what are your management
problems that you have and then develop
from that view about how things might
work and how you can best run your own
corruption record and the main thing
here is two things Information Systems
sort of in business schools for corrupt
people you might say the management
information system for the for the
corruption record and then the execution
capabilities or the enforcement of the
system you need to happen
who's most corruption requires a bunch
of people to work together certainly the
case in grand corruption where you need
a bunch of players to come together in
some form or fashion but even with petty
corruption where it's the customs
officers that ask for little bribes the
allocation of the post of customs
officer itself is Perle of a corruption
system in many cases and the allocation
of posts is managed and not random and
so just give you a few little points
here examples which are much inspired by
work that
diego gram betta who is a mafia
authority in oxford has made so first
when you run a corruption racket you
have to have an agreement with the other
part participants in your racket about
who is supposed to do what and who is
supposed to get how much money and who
is supposed to keep how much structure
etc etc as you need a way of tracking
that know so if you want to these are
all people who you know if you don't
watch them you know they're doing their
own thing and they're taking money away
from you know you want to have a little
bit of control she need an information
system
so why the way you run that information
system is something that can be quite
detrimental to economic growth example
two examples again from the Nigeria
cases in this case in early 90s and so
on one year we wrote a report on public
and public sector investment in Nigeria
and found that based on public data that
we had been able to pull together an
accounting data from the country there
were two billion dollars at least
missing and so I was the only report I
ever wrote in the World Bank Group that
was leaked ha and then got the Financial
Times first page article so at the same
time the Nigerian government had a a
program with the IMF and the IMF people
on their surveillance trip came and
dagger ah where are the two billion no
so and where is this money and so
finally they're cornered I wasn't there
but I'm told they corner at the top
economic policymaker who finally in the
hour of need pulled out a little
exercise book and in handwriting there
was where the money went and so you know
you can't prove that the guy was corrupt
or anything it's just you know he was on
top of his game he knew where the stuff
was he was making up for the
deficiencies of the incompetent
bureaucrats counting otherwise etc what
can he do ah and so but it seems to me
that this is one example where somebody
at the center of what presumably was a
corrupt system actually knew what was
going on people are not stupid they know
what
to be done and part of the deal is to
keep the official accounts obscure and
have the in official accounts just good
enough to manage your corruption ring
nevermind what happens to the economy so
you can't actually manage fiscal policy
very well if you don't know what is in
the accounts or another example that
goes in the same vein the National
Nigerian Petroleum Corporation which
then now is was the largest enterprise
in the country multi-billion dollars etc
never had serious accounts or if they
had accounts that were several years old
and once upon a time there was an
investigation and a fire broke out not
like a normal company's in the kitchen
but in the accounting department and
with all of this again it was not that
people were incompetent to top the head
of the company who was quite a competent
person and one day after having worked
for three years on a company we stitched
together as best as we could with some
gap with some loopholes etc an
accounting model of the company which
allowed projection of where the company
might be right now which you didn't
quite know and where it might go in the
future and just this is an atmospherical
little anecdote the head of the company
multi-billion dollars one of the most
important people in the economic
establishment of the country who
normally you couldn't see spend four
hours with us just looking at a Lotus
1-2-3 spreadsheet because it was the
first time ever that he had been able to
see what's happening in his company now
he presumably had made his own
compromises not wanting to know or not
able to know because to run the
corruption records you need your
information in ways that is good enough
for purpose but not as good that you can
really trace things and if you make sure
your accounts can't really trace what's
going on it's very hard to manage so
that's one thing the other thing is
enforcement if you want to enforce when
we talk about criminal enforcement
people think about knee braking poison
darts and stuff like that but if you're
a real criminal
you probably want to make sure people
don't break the rules so you don't have
to go to the hassle of breaking their
knees
cetera and pay people for that but makes
sure they don't so you either have
friends and family etc involved and the
competence of family members in managing
something not always assured or secondly
use people who have no other options who
have to be loyal to you who if they are
not loyal will not have a good
alternative lifestyle so it's much
better to run a corruption record with a
bunch of deadbeats then I mean a bunch
of very clever people who can go
elsewhere particular foreigners or
people who have options abroad and so
that's so that puts a spanner in the
works of managing things and one last
then an example of how enforcement can
really mess up economic productivity
again that guy you remember from the
airplane who looked after construction
projects yes okay how do you enforce
these things when things go wrong ok so
here's an example they build a bridge
from A to B for a municipality somewhere
in Nigeria so everybody was paid off
they built the bridge thing happened and
then I said here's the bill please pay I
mean Isabella said no you know not an
unusual occurrence in the country and
then they said ok fine you don't want to
pay we go back they took their big
caterpillar machinery drove up and down
the bridge it cracked and then the
municipality came running along sad you
destroyed our bridge I mean your bridge
you know so a bridge you know we build
it we paid for it you know when you pay
then you know it's your bridge
but not now it's our bitch so if we
break it you know what do you care
so they reconstructed the bridge were
paid etc but a lot of enforcement uses
rather physical control over things and
physical threats which are destructive
is obviously pure waste this whole
process and these things together well
that explains in a lot of cases why
things do not work and a last point in
about about enforcement just to make
that case in enforcing if you run your
corruption record
like in any criminal record a record one
way of enforcing loyalty is to have some
dirt on members of your racket and so
you want to have them exposed through
letters films photos or whatever in
being part to a corrupt transaction and
then it is when you have that when you
control the information and to some
extent the police that can try to mess
with information then it's actually very
useful in to run a corruption record to
have an independent judiciary because if
you if somebody in your record says you
know I'm no longer playing game I have
stolen let's suppose mr. Smith has
stolen more money than he was supposed
to steal you know and see other guys are
unhappy in the racket then you want to
enforce mr. Smith something against mr.
Smith if the judiciary if you have dirt
on him and a judiciary is independent
then by providing the dirt to the
independent judiciary you have a
reasonable chance and mr. Smith snows so
that he will be convicted if the
judiciary is corrupt itself then mr.
Smith can just pay off the guy and get
out of this so it's much better to run
your corruption record to have an
anti-corruption law on the books and
independent judiciary and control the
information flow so this is just one of
the many different paradoxical outcomes
that come about when you think in detail
about the incentives and the methods
involved in running a corruption racket
having said that so if we understand a
little bit about what we learn from
corruption about the business model
problems the question that is why should
any of this ever change and first point
is that people say we have to have an
anti-corruption Drive and do something
they all say which countries have
successfully done that and a typical
thing that you come back with is Hong
Kong and Singapore right and then odds
and sods little pieces of
systems but not much and any off is
there any country in the world that has
become very rich and really had a growth
spurt because of an anti-corruption
Drive not clear so as countries improved
some of them mostly Hong Kong Singapore
had relatively successful ones but it's
not obvious that corrupt and
anti-corruption policy per se is the big
thing that makes things change okay so
why would Eligius change why which
systems change
first of all typically the poor don't
and the downtrodden don't typically
overthrow and change systems it's either
parts of the elites or part of the
rising classes that want more out of the
system and so they look these people who
are looking for more out of the system
and - so looking for enrichment and I
would say the word enrichment is much
more useful in thinking about incentives
for change than corruption and another
example here
there is this person who you see on the
picture some of you may have seen in
brief very recently in a newspapers here
because he is much in the newspapers
these days in the United States but this
goes back to an event mr. Wolfensohn
then president of the World Bank
arranged with mr. Putin and his top
economic people in early 2000 in the
early part of 2000 and so here was as
Putin came into power an attempt to have
brainstorming about what are the key
policy issues on the economic side that
would face the Russian government and
mr. Wolfensohn had prepared three had us
prepared three different segments first
Dany Kaufman who is a very well known
anti-corruption advocate previously at
the World Bank now outside together with
a colleague then and he was supposed to
talk about governance and corruption
then it was I was supposed to talk about
markets and business environment and all
that and growth and then there was a
session on technology with this guy and
so off we went
we were supposed to talk for five
minutes and the rest was supposed to be
back and forth so Donnie Kauffman and
his colleague started talking about
anti-corruption and all the good things
about governance and you sort of felt it
in the room
Russian eyes were glazing over there was
andrey illarionov then economic adviser
to putin who said what about China you
know how does this thing work there why
are they growing so fast and the rest
was starting to fall asleep mr.
Wolfensohn became very nervous came over
to me and said you were supposed to be
second by you're going to go last we
have to revive this thing I will do the
technology thing next ok so then this
person came out who is this he's in the
newspaper every day these days but
usually not with a picture so this is my
CEO she's son his company Softbank is
currently taking over sprint for reasons
unknown to mankind
so the Masayoshi Son is a Softbank is an
IT kind of company are they used to own
and maybe still own Yahoo etc anyway
this was 2000 so height of the bob.com
area and so Masayoshi Sun comes in
segment number 2 stands up in front of
the assembled economic elite of than
Russia and says who's the richest person
in the world and the audience no gates
which at the time he was who's the
second richest person in the world and
the audience at the time he was he was
worth more than seventy billion dollars
at that later on he was became the
biggest loser of billions in history he
lost seventy billion dollars it still
had a few left
so that's anyway so the energy in the
room visibly changed
how did you do this
how can we imitate this stuff so mister
Wolfensohn was very right you know he
saw what would grab attention of people
mr. Putin stayed for four hours
altogether in that day then there was a
lunch Putin left but the other guys who
were left so all these tough economic
guys who did the only conversation about
it in the lunch table was how can we
make another billion so long story short
you know there is something to that
incentives to how you make them
and mr. mashallah CSUN question is
actually very clever if you ask yourself
if you really have only or mostly your
own enrichment in mind as I said who are
the richest people in the world it's
mostly people who have been
entrepreneurs had big firms etc etc very
few dictators a few of them make it into
the billionaires but not very high up
etcetera and then most of the corrupt
people in the world suffer from the same
syndrome that you have in Freakonomics
with drug dealers oh you know there's
this article about why drug dealers live
with their mother basically because they
don't have enough money to buy their own
apartment so it's not a very good
business altogether so this is a
corruption to the extent it is saps
economic growth and development it's
actually not very good so if you really
want to become rich think about how to
become how to make the country grow and
still keep your share of it that brings
me to the last slide what kind of
systems of our enrichment can we think
about and what can we usefully say about
the issues that arise and what might
happen and one attempt here is to
distinguish four or five different
systems the first one at the bottom left
the roving bandits is sort of the
Somalia story a bunch of looting
warlords are bleeding the country dry
and nobody has an incentive to invest
and do much because as soon as they have
a little bit of rich richer riches they
will be robbed this is not a recipe for
success
and the Warlord's can get a little money
some of them are lucky and have diamonds
and so on but very few of them can have
a happy relaxed holiday on the French
Riviera with their girlfriend etc so you
know the incentives if you could get
Somalia and other places to turn around
with by becoming a state just a pure
enrichment incentives are there too and
for some to take that bet and to make
the move then there's a second one which
I mentioned here called spigots or mr.
vitamin who wrote an article of with
similar type of terminology in 1997
called rent scribe scrapping this is
sort of a Nigeria story where you have a
source of rents oil money in this case
and the main attempt of the corrupt
people is to keep that flowing and and
steal as much as possible without regard
to the rest of economic development and
then you ask yourself how do you move up
from that is there for example a rents
extracting or rent scrapping our
spiggott country that made that this the
transition and arguably Indonesia did
that to a large degree first very
heavily dependent on oil resources then
moving out why what was one of the key
mechanisms in line with what I mentioned
first it was creating firms that can
create value and it was the saguaro
family and cronies etc that made that
happen
you may be upset as much as possible as
I was about human rights violations
associated with that about the
unfairness of the system etc but
Indonesia relative to other countries
like Nigeria did really well also for
most people so again a dilemma and when
we look at countries like Russia or many
countries in Africa now where everybody
wants to set up firms because this is
not just a transition phenomenon in Ex
communist countries it's also a
transition phenomenon in many other
countries where the state is very much
involved then the creation of new firms
the property rights to the new firms who
can have
who cannot etc is a highly bizarre
process unfair highly elite driven etc
but at the same time you know how else
would we do this you know maybe we have
wise Martians come and make sure humans
do the right thing but humans amongst
themselves may have a hard time solving
these problems without going through
very complicated phases full of dilemmas
then when you have managed the
transition from spigots to economy based
more on corporations like Indonesia or
if you never had raw material wealth
like Tunisia for example in to a great
degree you face the problem that Ben Ali
and others form a rule of Tunisia had
once you have your own firms you don't
want competition to come in and undercut
you and so but at the same time we know
that creative destruction is the real
driver at the end of the day of economic
growth and income increases and so we
need actually people to invest in
portfolios of companies and not in
individual companies so to take away the
incentive to protect the incumbents and
to allow our creative competition with
creative destruction to play and when
you ask yourself aren't there countries
in the world that have for some reason
by accident or otherwise found a way to
make that happen and what would the
country like that look like then you see
if you want to run your corruption
record in this way without a resource to
draw on from which to steal first of all
you want to have invest in a portfolio
of companies then you want an an Mis
system and information system that
allows you to track whether people stick
to their performance agreements or not
and one of the measures that seems to be
correlated in economic studies a lot
with productivity growth is export
success and so if you just give export
targets these can be measured actually
quite well and exports have the
advantage if your own statistical people
fake them the other side the importers
have statistics and it's more easily to
check the room for faking is not that
large and then you want a bunch of
secret account
where the money flows you want systems
inside the countries where you can't
trace where the money goes and then you
don't want too many players to make this
happen so a few conglomerates might do
well as long as there's enough internal
competition and finally when you start
looking at this it starts looking like
Korea so there's a chair ball until not
long ago all the accounts were lots of
secret accounts were allowed in Korea
etc etc corruption was clearly part of
the Korean case and to the extent that
public data exists you could actually
argue it's consistent with increasing
enrichment as the countries grew richer
maybe not as a share of total national
production but more for the individuals
involved and that then runs into still
the problem if you have secrecy and your
accounts don't fully reflects what's
going on it complicates your management
of firms anybody who's managed anything
knows information is really important
and good accounting system good
management information systems and so
you come into this debate about Korea
didn't make enough progress because lack
of corporate governance blah blah blah
Asian crisis and and so on and what is
the real answer to that well maybe it's
Singapore Singapore has found a way of
having the ruling elites have their
fingers in the investment vehicles that
are partly state-owned off having good
corporate governance excellent competent
managers very good rules extremely good
business environment and all of that in
a way that allows the elites to do well
and by bringing the whole economy up
which is the country in the world at
this time that has the highest level of
millionaires as a share of the
population is Singapore 17% according to
Boston Consulting this year in terms of
billionaires it's number two of number
one is Hong Kong number two is Singapore
with 16 billionaires in the city and the
at the same time it has one of the
most unequal income distributions in the
world that it also shares with with Hong
Kong a little worse than the US and a
little better than Brazil at the moment
and so this then all leaves the final
question what will happen to China so
the Chinese as they sit there and try
and deal with their economy may I'm
saying may may may have the option of
finding a way that allows enough
internal competition with the big
country and market that they have and
the many players that they have and a
lot of private entrepreneurs that are
actually not part of the Communist Party
etc to have creative destruction play
Allah if you can then combine that with
a way for the party to extract enough
money through ownership of holding
corporations financial sector
organizations etc they may be able to
pull off that trick that Singapore did
you know just saying maybe maybe maybe
and this is a different story about the
future of China than what you may have
read in darkness amol oh and mr.
Robinson's book about why nations fail
where they say China with this on its
current course will run into a brick
wall
depending on how one thinks about these
things maybe not and then the financial
crisis as my last remark is actually
providing economists legitimation for
whatever that's worth to the ownership
of by a state or a state involvement in
the ownership of financial institutions
after all it seems that most state most
financial institutions at the end of the
day when things go wrong are owned by
the state anyway so because the taxpayer
is there to provide a helping hand at
the end of the day so the the advantages
of pure private ownership are not as
clear in the financial sector as
elsewhere thank you very much
and now let's turn to a professor
Timothy Frey and I should have mentioned
that Tim's latest book is called
building states and markets after
communism the perils of polarized
democracy published by Cambridge in 2010
which was awarded the best book prize by
the comparative democratization section
of the American Political Science
Association and also the Hewitt prize
for the best book published in political
economy by the association of Slovak
East European and Eurasian studies so
Tim now that Kim has succeeded in
embarrassing me I want to thank
professor Klein for a really great talk
the best part for me of the talk was the
tone we hear so much preaching about
corruption and it's really refreshing
for someone to understand the complexity
of the issue and not to make the blanket
statements that oh corruption is the
bane of all evil and only we got rid of
corruption everything would be great in
the world or people you know poopoo in
corruption in saying Oh iris corruption
everywhere everybody you know so we
shouldn't really worry about it and the
some of the important insights here are
just that we really have to have a much
more nuanced understanding of how
corruption affects people's incentives
to engage in productive or unproductive
behavior and a couple a couple of
general comments one under two broad
themes and I'll have a couple of more
random more random thoughts first of all
on measuring corruption I was a graduate
student and you know some of my initial
research and some of the research I've
done over a long time are these firm
level surveys and the first ones I did
we asked a bunch of questions on
corruption and over time I've just
gotten away from them because I'm just
I'm just really don't know
what we're really getting just because
of response bias and particularly when
you're doing them in a country like
Russia which in the 1990s was relatively
open and filling people were willing to
talk about corruption
it just becomes much more difficult to
get people to talk openly about it
and when we start to think about cross
national comparisons of corruptions
using the firm level surveys we really
have to be careful about this type of
really type of response bias where in
countries where people are afraid to
actually talk about corruption things
might look a lot better than they than
they are in in in reality you know and
also the thing about corruption is that
people have a lot of incentives to
because it's so difficult to measure
people not only have a lot of incentives
they also have a lot of ability to
manipulate perceptions about corruption
where you know if a firm is doing well
and wants to keep somebody out of the
market one response is to say oh don't
enter this market it's terrible it's so
corrupt here you know I you'll never be
able to make a penny here as they're as
they're taking their their money to the
bank so even before we think about
corruption as an actual barrier to entry
to keep firms out we can understand that
the incumbents have a lot of incentives
to inflate these kinds of these kinds of
perceptions right and you know there are
people there is an incentive to hide
corruption and say that that you're not
engaging it but another way is to know
the strategies to flaunt your corruption
I'm so powerful that I can go engaging
corrupt behavior and nothing not nothing
can can happen to me so I've done
interviews with people where you know I
you just don't really know what you're
getting whether they're boasting about
what they can get away with when they're
talking to you and inflating the
the level of corruption when actually is
much lower than what they're saying
versus people who are saying oh I've
never paid a bribe in my life here
although I've been doing business in
Russia for 20 years not not a very
likely scenario also so these types of
cross national comparisons are
especially problematic because people
have different notions about what
corruption is so not only is there a
problem in trying to get people to
answer truthfully there's also there's
also a problem in that sorry I lost my
train of thought for a second there
what's considered corruption in one
setting is not considered corruption in
another so these kinds of anchoring
problems that we often see in all kinds
of cross national research thank you
very much are are much aggravated when
we talk about corruption right so when
we ask somebody out how frequently does
somebody does a firm like yours pay
bribes well what could be frequently in
one country could be infrequently in
another country although the actual
number might be actually the same so
also we're not always sure whether we're
capturing trends or whether we're
capturing levels you know people could
say Oh corruption is really bad because
we're starting from a very low base and
I had to pay a bribe
so it's really bad here or it could be
that you're actually capturing the the
actual level of corruption which could
be very low we say oh I only paid a
bribe last month
you know so not really so bad one of
there's been a lot of progress though I
think in terms of trying to think more
sophisticated ly about corruption
there's some studies been olkin and some
of his colleagues have came up with a
very ingenious way of measuring
corruption what they say objectively
although it's very difficult to
generalize about this as they studied
road building in Indonesia and they were
able to drill core samples of the roads
and then match those up with the
reported expenses that the companies
used to build the roads and they could
show the degree to which companies were
under reporting over reporting their
their actual expenses when they were
actually diluting the the quality of the
products they were putting in the road
one of the things that has become very
popular now are these list experiments
where we did one recently in Moscow
where we are interested in petty
corruption and bribery among the police
and to get around the problem of people
not wanting to admit that they engage in
corruption what we did is we asked 1,600
Muscovites we split the sample randomly
into two so the two groups are alike in
every way there are old people and same
number of old people same number of
young people just randomly assigned
people into two groups so one group gets
three questions that are completely non
sensitive right
have you watched a movie about the
police in the last year have you ever
asked a policeman for corruption for
directions and some other to someone in
your does any of your close friends work
in the police or some other question
that people would be really you know be
happy to answer and we say don't tell us
which of these questions you answer yes
- just tell us how many of them right so
we get a wrong number so average say on
average say 1.5 percent of the people
say that they engaged in at least in the
number of these activities right so the
other group we give exactly the same
three questions but then we had a fourth
question where we say if you ever paid a
bribe to a police officer in the last 12
months again don't tell us which of
these four your interest which of these
four that you actually said yes - just
tell us the number right so the idea is
to try to give the respondent some
plausible deniability
to engage in activities that are
sensitive or to report socially
undesirable activities for
these this method was actually initially
used in studies of race relations in the
US where there was three very questions
do these three things make you mad and
then so was companies polluting the
environment athletes making a lot of
money and then the u.s. is poor showing
at the Olympics or something like that
and then the other group they had the
same three questions and it was if an
African American family moved in next
door so how many of these things would
make you angry and then all you need to
do is look at the differences in the
mean responses between these two groups
to find out what the actual level is or
at least reported level of people
engaging in these sensitive topics are
so what we thought in Moscow was that of
the people who had contact with the
police so it's not everybody 20 percent
reported that they had paid a bribe and
this is I think much closer to the truth
than the surveys that just asked people
directly where you say you know have you
ever paid a bribe to the police officers
which in Russia the air the average
response is around four or five percent
so those this might be a somewhat a
better way on effects of corruption I
agree that that we can it's very easy to
overestimate the economic impacts of
corruption there probably a lot smaller
than the negative impacts of lobbying or
state capture particularly comparing the
lobbying power to forms of petty
corruption there's some nice papers that
demonstrate this also responses to
corruption can also be costly right so I
run the center at the higher economic
School in Moscow and we go through the
process of cosa cooky the state
procurement process which takes up three
months is incredibly burdensome and you
know eats up huge amounts of man-hours
and probably you know on average it is
reducing corruption in some way because
it's more transparent and there's the
people like Navalny who are not
constantly on the
on the internet revealing the most
egregious violations of cosa cooky but
for us the honest people trying to go
through this process is horrible so the
worst thing is just trying to be an
honest person in a situation where the
government has put in place all these
mechanisms that make it hard too hard to
engage in corruption a couple other
points now it may be true that there are
no billionaire autocrats right but
there's also probably no poor middle
class autocrats either so they tend to
do pretty well when we open up the bank
account to these guys even the ones who
say that they are say that they are you
know very populist and for the working
class they typically have their Swiss
bank accounts as well also gam betas
work is great and one question we want
to ask right is if mafias were more
efficient than States than we would see
States out competing mafias and mafias
would be running the world rather than
States right so one of the points that
he makes is that mafias work very hard
to make sure that they're providing
private goods and they were pretty hard
to say if you don't pay then you're not
going to get protection
whereas States ideally are offering more
public goods which allow people to
engage in hopefully activities that are
more efficiency enhancing on Singapore
and Hong Kong it is striking how
frequently people refer to those is the
6x cases because it's really hard to
point to successful cases we on a
national level there probably are more
cases where we could look at smaller
levels where incremental changes have
been made in corruption but we also need
be careful not that not to make too much
of generalizing from Hong Kong and
Singapore which are really specific
cases you know
Singapore's governance problems are very
different from most other countries just
given its role in the global economy and
it's it's its geography and its relation
to other fast-growing economies in the
region a couple other points is that
this diversification away from the
status quo of corruption or is really
difficult because corruption benefits
the incumbents now that's the problem
that this is really a political problem
rather than purely one of thinking about
the rules as if the rules were
exogenously put in place and we can just
change the rules and everybody's
behavior will change but you know those
rules are put in place because they're
benefiting specific people and the often
the incumbents who are benefiting from
the status quo will often be the ones
most pushing or most talking about what
a great thing the market is when they're
precisely the ones that are benefiting
from all the imperfections in the market
and not the Luigi Zingales had a great
line the other day where he said there's
lots of pro-business lobbying in
Washington but there's almost zero Pro
market lobbying in Russia in Washington
which is a nice which is a nice a nice
line and again on the importance of
information that's exactly I think a
great point and one of the reasons why
Montesinos this peruvian national
security adviser who was paying off
televisions and television stations and
on the orders of millions of dollars to
pro to run pro Fujimori stories if you
ever get the chance to go on the
internet just type in Montesinos tapes
and look at the videos and i show these
in my class and the jaws just drop when
you see the guy opened the suitcase and
pull out the stack of money to put on
the table and then reach back in and
pull out another one reach back in and
pull out another one this goes on for a
little while so they really they really
do have a great effect so one of the
reasons to for writing these contracts
was for these enforcement purposes and
if i go down you're gonna go down to
because you sign this the other problem
which is keeping
track of all the obligations that people
hadn't incurred on both sides of this
corruption deal because he was bribing
you know hundreds probably thousands of
people we don't have a precise estimate
because a lot of the evidence
unfortunately is gone but just a
management problem of trying to
understand corruption is really
important there was really nice of
professor Kline could I put an emphasis
on that so that I'll give my academic
point of view about some thoughts and
thinking about corruption I'll turn it
over to Gayle well it's a pleasure to be
here thank you to Kim for inviting me to
participate I think that dr. Klein's
work is really a breath of fresh air in
our efforts to understand corruption and
deal with it effectively and his work
really sir resumes with my experience I
do a lot of work and developing
economies particularly in the in banking
and the former countries of the former
Soviet Union and one of the things I
repeatedly observe is how ill-equipped
so many of us are to understand
corruption let alone just to try to deal
with it in an effective way just
recently I had a conversation with a
young banker in Kazakhstan we were
talking about corruption and this guy's
like in his 20s can you hear me okay
and he told me that without anyone ever
actually having told him he basically
knows what it would cost to get anything
done in Kazakhstan and when I asked him
where about it he said it's just sort of
information that's kind of in the air
which you know I can only equate with
the fact that I kind of know what's
going on with Brad Pitt and Angelina
Jolie nobody told us but the information
is kind of in the air and you know I was
thinking about that and if you could
trust that with the experience you know
that we have as New Yorkers where every
Christmas judging from the articles
about it in their times no one knows how
much to tip their superintendent of
their building
really in that information is it not in
the air as far as I'm aware it just sort
of really underscores for me would it
would it really big challenge this is
and I had two comments I wanted to make
one very specifically about dr. Klein's
the paper that he wrote in those
comments tonight and then one that I
consider sort of a parallel comment on I
was very interested in the idea you know
the sort of progression of how you can
get enrichment with growth by developing
it to corporations and then sort of
portfolios but one of the things that
really struck me that someone might be
interested in doing research on actually
is the because I do a lot of work on
boards of directors and working with
corporate governance the whole issue of
how you would establish new effective or
at least quasi effective corporate
governance in these organizations
because one of the curious aspects of
you know the corporate governance model
which is that the shareholders appoint
the board of directors and the board of
directors are responsible to the
shareholder for making sure that value
is maximized in the company and I can
tell you from my own experience you know
if there's one shareholder in that
person's oligarch you know what really
are you supposed to do so it's sort of
interesting if you think about if you're
if you're appointed by an elite and some
you know corrupt country you know some
it elite in some country was a high
level of corruption or if you're
appointed by you know a state agency in
some country where there's a high level
of corruption
first of all do they really want you to
do your job but secondly how do you
really do your job because the point is
to get you know as much money back to
them as you can but maybe they're able
to get more money back not because
you've helped the company become more
transparent but because they can help
get it another other way so I think it's
it's a very complicated question that
you know we can't resolve you know
tonight but I think that you know if I
were asked by the World Bank to sort of
help work on a project like this they
could be very interesting and very
important to try to think that through
very carefully and another sort of
wrinkle to that is that you you can
really only do it with local people you
can't parachute in you know people like
me you can't parachute in foreigners
because we will never really understand
how that system works and if people
don't want it to work include
the fact that you know in my imagination
of how a business works particularly a
state-owned business it's not just you
know the so-called owner who's getting
money out of that business it's
everybody surrounding it it's all of the
you know the workers up and down the
chain who are getting money out of the
business so you know you go into one of
these big companies as a foreign Borden
of her and you're just gonna be
completely clueless because they're
gonna you know eat you for lunch however
what I think is sort of interesting is
that you know no matter I'm not trying
to say that I don't think this is work
is obviously it has but I think it's
something interesting to look at what I
also find interesting though is that you
know there are a lot of state-owned
companies and elite owned companies and
countries that have you know very bad
corruption ratings yet you also see a
great deal of foreign interest in
investing in these companies and I'll
get back to this point but I think
there's a pretty interesting disconnect
between what we say is important to us
and we say corruptions not having you
know transparency and non corruption is
important to us we say that good
corporate governance is important to us
but if you look at how big investment
banks invest and where your mutual fund
and pension is going it's sort of
telling a different story the sort of
parallel observation I wanted to make
has to do with my experience with
related party lending and the reason I
think it's sort of parallel is if you
think of corruption as sort of a coping
mechanism in a dysfunctional economy as
a society I've come to think of related
party lending also as a coping mechanism
so related party lending is just you
know it's loans made to people who work
in a bank so if I were say you know but
whether you know it's important when
it's loans to senior management the
owner the president so if for example I
owned 75% of a bank and the bank made
loans to companies that I also loan
owned those would be related party loans
and they can be very tricky because
they're very they're they're non
transparent and it's very hard for an
outsider to determine you know the
outsider being a depositor and investor
a rating agency
even a board member that's not really an
outsider very difficult for someone to
assess whether that is actually the best
use of the money so there's always been
you know there's almost even a whiff of
corruption about related party lending
the in the sense that you know
corruption is someone in a person in a
position of power using that power to
their advantage you know so I'm the
president I'm the owner of the bank and
I you know convinced know what every one
of the bank is too afraid not to make
loans to my company so I'm taking unfair
advantage on related party lending is
not really an issue in the u.s. you
don't hear about it here because our
banks are too big
Jamie Dimon you know whatever if he
actually owned another business alone
that JPMorgan Chase would make to one of
his businesses wouldn't get up on the
radar screen but if the it's a very big
issue in emerging economies because
banks there tend to be not that old
founded by one person a group of people
they often have other businesses and
those businesses need money so when you
go to a lot of developing economies and
work with banks it's a very big issue
and it's something that foreign bankers
you know from the US and Western Europe
are very uncomfortable with and we
therefore we try to we just you know try
to limit it
you know America Lee but what I've you
know I can't really actually say this to
bankers but I'll say it to you what I've
actually come to pretty much believe
over the years is that related party
lending in the developing economies and
at which I've worked it actually makes a
lot of sense because you know imagine
you're a banker you know you're working
in a country with a weak legal system
with very weak non not unreliable
information at that credit history
unreliable financial information I mean
who are you going to lend to your best
loans are going to be loans you make to
the people that you know maybe to your
own business maybe to your partner's
business and those are the loans that
actually make sense and so I think that
the conversation that foreign bankers
this isn't I'm trying to tie this into
corruption the conversation that foreign
bankers should be having with local
bankers is about
how to understand this and how to
differentiate between the loans that
actually are quite good for the bank and
those that you know that aren't you know
insider loans that are too good
companies for what you get a good profit
and you have good collateral and the
ones that are going to bring the bank
down we don't have that conversation we
put limits on it and then what happens
is that you know the one or two banks
that actually observe the limits they're
disadvantaged because they can't grow as
quickly as their competitors and the
only thing that happens is that the
bankers because their rules don't make
sense to them come up with ways to
conceal their related party loans so
what we actually end up doing is we're
sort of inadvertently kind of fostering
non transparency and kind of potentially
corruption and I think that that what
underlies what I was trying to say about
corporate governance and this issue with
related party lending and there's other
examples I could bring but I'll just
stick with those for right now is that a
fear that we're creating we as foreign
investors are creating this kind of
superstructure Potemkin village kind of
situation where we pretend that we're
investing in companies that operate and
think like companies on the new york
stock exchange but the actual reality in
Russia or Ukraine or you know Somalia or
wherever is really very different on we
can pretend we can think or we can
pretend that what we're doing is
legitimate but the people in the country
is where we're doing this you know they
know that they don't have good corporate
governance and they know that there's
corruption and they know that there's a
related party lending so to them I think
there's a risk that the foreign
investors look either stupid or naive
unto one hand or they look like
hypocrites and I think for those you
know the experienced local investor for
the experienced people in experiment
experienced people in these local
markets no bankers who've gotten their
MBAs from Harvard who understand how the
system is supposed to work I fear that
they look at us and they think that
we're a bunch of hypocrites and the
thing that sort of really get some my
nerves is that you know again in the
countries of the former Soviet Union I
feel sometimes as if our
havior is kind of reminiscent of you
know kind of late communist party where
we're saying one thing and we're doing
another which is why I you know really
enjoyed reading dr. Klein's paper those
comments tonight because I think that
the only way to kind of get away from
that is by really being honest about
what we don't understand trying to
understand it having a conversation with
the people that were working with so
that ultimately we can hopefully you
know help them and their Connor's but
also ultimately help ourselves because I
think we really do need to be more
consistent between what we say is
important to us about you know
corruption and corporate governance and
what we actually do so thank you for
such a stimulating reworks Michael do
you want to respond before we open it up
to Q&A okay so if you have questions or
comments please feel free to line up
behind the microphone and when you make
your question or comment please identify
yourself by name and your institution
okay Kim thank you my name is Cynthia
Roberts I teach it Hunter College to the
University and also occasionally here at
Columbia thank you all for your
insightful comments the question I have
actually touches on a piece of all of
your remarks and it seems a kind of
contradiction or a paradox on the one
hand we would expect that international
standards more information would help
reduce corruption or at least change the
rules and we would see that contrary to
what Gayle said perhaps in joint
ventures right foreign companies
investing in Russia or elsewhere have
higher rule-based standards even if
there is some hypocrisy and we would
expect a set of different outcomes and
the literature shows that similarly when
German companies and I did some
interviews in Germany asked this
question invest in Russia you know they
take the long term view but they expect
the Russians to operate on German
standards not vice-versa whether this is
a Bach
see or not it's an interesting question
so my question is on the international
domestic linkages one would expect the
outside rules if they're more rule
governed to prevail but each of you seem
to suggest in different ways that isn't
always so and that it's the stability if
I hear you correctly it's the stability
of the rules on the one hand that sets
the equilibrium as opposed to maybe
changing rules so there's high levels of
investment we heard in many corrupt
countries obviously there's money to be
made and if there's a stable set of
rules then you get one set of outcomes
on the other hand if there's growth
doesn't correlate so countries are
growing even despite corruption in Italy
until recently it was also a good
example not just the BRIC countries that
I work on so what is there to be is
there my question is really is there a
better set of international domestic
linkages that we can learn from this or
is it really more about stable rules and
information as opposed to raising
standards and reducing corruption
because if you can grow fast and still
be very corrupt that's not a huge
incentive for leaders of corrupt
countries to change and I'll end with
this specific Russia comment reflective
our interest in president Putin's first
speech what was really the most striking
to me was his statement that of his
recent inauguration that he wanted
Russia to come up I think I forget the
exact number 20 spots in the Ease of
Doing Business Survey within some
ridiculously small number of years like
five years why should he care hundred
and twenty to twenty by 2020
one I'll get you a question on this very
point though is that there's some
arguments out there I don't know that
the case well enough is that Georgia was
very effective in raising its core in
doing business in the world precisely
because they knew what the indicators
were and those are the things that they
concentrated on and it
well the bleed that that's probably a
good thing but some of the other people
have expressed some skepticism about the
extent to which the law on the books
which they're doing business is
especially concerned with really mapped
up with the the reality and if countries
can game the system that way then the
measures probably are causing the
behavior rather than being reflective of
what's actually going on talk about the
actual question for what it's worth I
would think there is some work as you
will know that unstable unpredictable
forms of corruption are worse than
predictable forms of corruption there
are some people who find that in the
statistics I'm not so sure that that yet
gets at the real thing I would talk too
much about Nigeria no but I would argue
that Nigeria is an extraordinarily
stable country or they may have
revolving elites but underneath things
are very very stable in Nigeria you have
had for many years projects going ahead
regardless of any change in relative
prices Oh things just keep going once
you have agreed who gets what it'll
continue the poster child of Nigerian
white elephants is the edge or kuta
steel mill project which was dreamed up
in 1964 in a consultant's report and
then was I think finished and produced
the first steel in two thousand and
something and then closed down again and
then
opened two years ago or so you know
billions and billions of dollars on
outdated Soviet technology to completely
you nobody has any it just doesn't make
any sense but it just keeps going ahead
you know stability above all and so
separate secondly I know companies that
think that the rules on taxation for
example in certain sectors are more
uncertain in the US than they are in
Nigeria and in Nigeria as part of the
rules may not be official but you know
what you what the interests are and it's
very stable so I'm not so sure about a
how you measure what is really stability
and what is not number two there will be
systems where I'm not sure that's that
kind of stability is the issue but more
whether if you're I would just to push a
little bit that the taxonomy that I put
forward is if you're in a bad system of
corruption and if the elites are stable
around that that's not good so you would
want to have some change that moves
Nigeria in the direction of Indonesia
I'm sorry for example two quick points
one is we often debate in the courses I
teach about and this is a much broader
debate about local knowledge versus best
practices and you know you can talk
about the EU accession in Eastern Europe
which mean people I think is generally
been a good thing as being an
off-the-shelf here the rules
abide by them you know more or less it's
worked we can also think of lots of
cases where taking rules off the shelf
plopping them down in a very different
place in producing very bad outcomes we
can also have lots of informal rules and
local knowledge that help get around you
know market imperfections and various
kinds of obstacles and we could also
point to lots of informal rule
and local knowledge it's really just
done to de buttress the local elites and
to keep the market small but to keep
their share of it relatively big so we
really need to come down a level level
of abstraction and really look at you
know who's involved what are the stakes
you know what are the cost of getting
information about what's going on and
then we can start to say something about
how we change the situation but that's
really hard that's really hard to do and
for all the reasons Gael was pointing
out it's even harder for people who are
kind of outside the system to do so
so our greatest hope is elites who want
to enrich themselves improve the system
hi I'm Janet Johnson I teach at Brooklyn
College and to Tim I say I I have paid a
bribe to the Russian police it was not
because I wanted to but I had to I don't
think anyway um I'm not a political
economist I'm a competitiveness and for
me I I'm just really struggling with the
ways in which we talk about corruption
using this transactional definition that
transparency international uses and it
just seems like politics is really
missing corruption equals bribes and if
that's what corruption means why not
just call it bribes embezzlement or
whatever like what what does it add and
then you know the focus is mostly about
inefficiency like that's the frame of
our conversation today and that's just
not not the way that I see corruption
you know and even in dr. Klein's
comments it's this question about you
know one of the things that you said was
that the system of rules is what matters
right if it's pretty simple then people
kind of follow the rules so isn't it
really the rules that we should be
talking about and then I'll end with
I've been writing on Iceland you know
which is another you know small case it
doesn't really matter very much it can't
be generalized but Iceland in 2004 five
and six I think maybe I'm off of the
years was number one on transparency and
corruption perception index and I would
argue that in fact Iceland was
incredibly corrupt in which there was a
small group of elite that had taken over
the political system and engaged an
insider privatization and in essence
captured the state and those things
inside her privatization in state
capture I think are corruption and I
think are actually more problematic
corruption at least politically and and
and it was a pots and pans revolution
led by women that overthrew the
government now I'm not sure that their
system has can been completely
eradicated of the corruption but it was
a People's Revolution
in that case that did so I would say
that both we need to think more about
the politics I mean what's the
connection between patronage patrimonial
ism clientelism and all these sort of
broader political questions but also I
think that there is a political question
about how we get rid of corruption as
well that isn't just about Elysee but
there is a role I hope for people and
engaging more transparently and it's not
by not paying bribes necessarily because
bribes just may be part of the system
but there are other ways of getting rid
of corruption I would have thought there
are always three dimensions to look at I
mean I don't know all the answers either
but three dimensions to look at one
other other rule what is what is legal
what is legitimate and what is efficient
so the economists talk a lot about
efficiency
the lawyers talk a lot whether it's
legal or not and much of what you said
was really about legitimacy whether the
processes which were ostensibly legal of
influence-peddling of various types and
so on and you sort of pointed out to
that sort of lobbying on campaign
finance and so on which some people also
call corruption is goes back to some
concept of natural justice that whatever
whoever has in her his or her mind so
this is in terms of thinking about this
I would just say that and then when it
comes to change processes I just don't
think that one can hope that corrupt
systems massively go away because the
good people with all the legitimate
intentions will rise and abolish
one needs to think about the legitimate
or illegitimate interests of those who
hold levers of power however
objectionable that might be thanks a
couple points one of the things that we
find in the this this police study it's
still very raw so you know I could look
at the data again and I'll take back
everything I say but one of the things
we that seems to be very strong is that
people who vaporize don't like it very
much
so this notion that Oh everybody pays
bribes in Russia everybody's okay with
it you know this does not seem to be
borne out at all by the data and there's
lots of other questions that we asked
about conditions under which it's okay
to pay bribes and you know the numbers
are very close to 80 85 90 percent say
you know that under normal conditions
that I'm paying bribes is not not really
acceptable on measuring corruption it's
interesting how even Transparency
International has really walked back
from the Corruption Perceptions Index
which gave them their first splash in
1995-96 and now when you go to their
webpage it's hard to find it they bury
it away because they they you know you
know in some sense of their credit they
they recognize there are lots of
problems with it and they had this huge
footnote in there about what not to do
with the data that lots of people just
ignore you know the method they change
year to year and you should look at one
country over time or at the comparing
across all these kind you know anyway
there's I mean one of the the the that's
a mo gluon Robinson book that wine
elites fail this was for political
scientist I thought this was this was
great news for us you know the state
matters elites matter power matters you
know these are all the things that were
supposed to have have given some thought
to so particularly when political
scientists with our inferiority complex
you know economists come to reach the
similar kinds of conclusions maybe maybe
shouldn't I don't know can i interject a
question here um taking the role of
chair and using the prerogative the
chair I wonder if what it takes to
change a stable system of corruption
that seems to be generally in place
where people know how things work is a
shock to the system and I'm wondering I
mean I don't know a lot about Iceland as
the as the question was just asked but
it would seem to me that one of the
things that created change in Iceland
was the incredible shock of the economic
collapse and I don't know anything about
Singapore to know if there was a shock
that that created things but I I've just
actually written a book about how
warlords will not become state builders
I find warlords this local power broker
so it's a little bit different from
roving bandits but you know one of the
arguments I make is that if you've spent
your whole life being really good at
what you're doing and that is what has
allowed you to get ahead and your
networks are what make you profitable
why would you take the risk of changing
that system when you know that you can
continue to profit the way that things
are and you know prospect theory from
political psychology tells you that
people are less willing to take risks on
behalf of change and on behalf of of
rewards than they are to take risks in
order to prevent losses and so that
would seem to mean that people who are
comfortable and the status quo elites in
the existing system would want to
preserve it rather than change it so
where does the change come from I would
have thought don't know they would have
thought of shocks are clearly one thing
accidents
why did Korea after the Korean well the
Korean War was sort of a shock but then
why did Korea afterwards started to well
not entirely clear but that's a case
where I don't know enough about the
details but you know the questions I
would have is they looked at obviously
at Japan and imitate it something that
seemed to work somewhere else and I was
different from what they had before
so surely the original people who did
this were used to something maybe that
was sufficiently upset by a shock that
they groped around for something new and
occasionally people do take bets and I
would say then the people that do take
bets and have a chance of implementing
their bets tend to be people who are
have some level of power and have some
interest in enriching themselves and
then finally there are the revolutions
and the revolutions to the extent of a
better but from from what I read most
rise revolutions are the process of some
rising class makes the revolution not
the downtrodden they may be used in the
process may make some revolt etc but the
French Revolution the Chinese Revolution
etc these are rising classes that made
that happen and so there's always this
there has to be some level of power some
interest in make and more of it a little
shock well accidents and in a real
historians I would say there is no
theory everything is special sorry yeah
if we think about Russia you know one
argument about the pattern of policy
making is that exogenously Cline's in
the price of oil in the early Putin
years when a lot of the policies were
things I think most economists would
agree were good things Tax Reform labor
code reform customers reform even bank
reform for a while and then oil prices
shot up and people understood that this
wasn't temporary so it took a little
while to kick in so that by 2004-2005
Bank who needs Bank reform
who needs you know these other kinds of
reforms so the shocks can
they have distributional consequences
they make some groups weaker and
stronger and the hope is that the shock
makes the groups that are benefiting
from the bad status quo weaker in some
ways and forces them to share the wealth
a little bit more broadly threats as
well sometimes external threats can
force leaders to think a little bit more
long term threats of exit to people
leaving
they say the German the the Berlin Wall
came down for the same reason that went
up to keep East Germans in East Germany
so you would know better than not I
wouldn't I would just one thing to my
mind this is an I wonder what role the
following plays this is an episode in
history when countries grow faster than
ever before on average now economists
have despaired about being explained or
explaining how to do the snow build
easterly and others have found out that
economic theory doesn't really tell you
but that despair is offset by a reality
that there's more and more of this
growth and when I again anecdotal
perception when I look at the the
reactions of say African countries to
the doing business report or saw they're
all groping around how can we become so
successful and so the the realization at
this point in history that you can
actually get so much richer than you
were must play some role in shaping the
willingness to take bets off otherwise
I'm about Harris I'm a non-academic if
as a United States investor I decide to
invest in one of these corrupt countries
Asia Latin America Russia or China I
mean you know there's you know some of
the corruption in all of them well it is
easy for me to avoid the the United
States laws against corruption as it
will be for
tap into the corrupt scenarios of these
countries don't have direct observations
about what happens the general
perception I would have thought is that
efforts by countries like the u.s.
through the entire Practices Act it's
very cool I mean it's very strict yeah
it's it does probably influence a bit
what people do at a minimum you have to
find new ways of hiding things so it
makes it more costly etc and I would
have thought if if being corrupt was
such a world-beating successful model
then you know like what was the example
you gave the Mafia's then the whole
world would move towards more corruption
but there is this thing that sticking to
some sensible rules and behaving halfway
reasonably and letting yourself be
pushed by people like US companies that
want to stick to a few rules might
actually just tip people over the edge
and behave a little better and then the
last one is a pure anecdotes this goes
to back to your point about nobody likes
paying bribes by the way nobody likes to
pay taxes but in Nigeria in in the
beginning my first project was on a gas
pipeline project and we had an
enormously lengthy process of going
through a procurement and so at the end
of the day it was reasonably clear that
compared to other pipelines that had
been let without this procurement
process this process had saved the
country several hundred million dollars
so probably half to two-thirds of what
they would otherwise have paid apart
from that the the thing is that the
people we worked with while they were
obnoxious many times during a
process later on were proud of having
gone through this process so these
individual inclinations most as long as
the world has it goes to your Iceland
and other points as long as there are
people around who have some sense of
legitimacy or what we call a conscience
and so on around and then the right shot
comes and the right incentives and the
right anti crack toises act or whatever
it can help create the the instant
instances where things tip into a better
way and if that then proves to work
better and these countries advance then
sort of this mechanism of Darwinian
selection plays out so mutation has
happened and then it grows about
information is important here I think
and if you look at what the state
procurement process in Russia has done
is it's allowed alexander Navalny and
his whole group to just scour the
internet find the most egregious abuses
post them and it causes no you knows no
sense of small grief for the current
incumbents they hate it it's the
information out there is something that
is it is very costly in my land mr.
Novotny in jail
unfortunately at some point but this
shows that these strategies for raising
the costs you know I think it has had an
impact on all kinds of things like
governmental approval ratings and you
know it's not surprising that the
government is not making life easy for
them precisely because this is a
successful kind of strategy
Natacha densa with the visiting scholar
with the Herman Institute and also I'm
involved in a number of energy projects
as a practical as a practitioner I have
actually I have to confess never been
interested in corruption as a russian
they're skeptical so it always is
inevitable part of the society but I
enjoyed your panel very much though and
I have a question about Russia your
assessment what is going on and I don't
know if it's corruption or even more I
just tell you what what I mean I think
we're witnessing right now
restructuring by the government there
are open restructuring of the precious
asset of the nation the land and what I
mean take two things I'm talking about
Moscow and suburb of moscow moscow
oblast suddenly the government is saying
or we're moving some of the parts
officials to the Moscow suburb air it's
nobody knows under what rules it's done
it seems legally they're doing it under
doctrine of eminent domain right which
is good for whether there is necessary
for public purpose we're taking your
ownership right but the reality is is it
is reshuffling the land they're taking a
lot of people a very concern in Moscow
they're filing they're filing class
class actions
class action suits but guess who is
winning of course government so people
are taking legally people are taking
their property away and now the second
project everybody is talking about right
now is the development of the Far East
which is necessary for Russia it is
really important the question is though
how it is going to be develop developed
in under what format and what they are
saying that again it will be a state
corporation or they created right now
ministry
of eastern development which we'll be
taking from the federal rules it will
not be obliged to any rules it will be
like some special regulations and 40% of
the Russian land with all its natural
resources will be somehow divided
between semi federal semi private
corporations I I would talk about
corruptions I will talk about robbery I
will talk about what I don't know about
Russia so I can speculate freely the I
would have thought what what you say
what that evokes in my mind is in a lot
of countries land rights had not been
clearly assigned to private parties for
a long time so all over Africa
developing world to some degree in
former Soviet former communist countries
and the process of establishing property
rights is taking place in a lot of
places property rights were also
established in firms land etc and when
you don't have a clear system by which
property rights have been established
you have all sorts of subterfuges and
weird ways of establishing property
rights which too many people look highly
illegitimate whether you call it
corruption or not whatever but is it
legitimate or not and you can endlessly
and this is where you need power
structures to create new property rights
to make them stable but at the same time
power structures can abuse this and so
you one of these dilemmas again your
table she a new regime and to think that
new regimes are established by John
Rawls sitting behind the veil of
ignorance and doing the best for all
people no it's a bunch of venal people
who are involved in a process and so
that's what that sounds like to me and
in that sense the old anarchist mr.
Putin was right know that the property
is theft at that point you could from a
legitimacy point of view
although not from a legal point of view
you could understand that comment
Plunkett of Tammany Hall which is
another book I teach I tell my students
if you only read one book about American
politicians you read this one it's about
the ward boss in New York City in the
nineteenth century
and he says I've never engaged in
corruption I just seen my opportunities
and I took them one of the examples is
oh I hear the city is gonna buy up some
land so I buy it up first and you know
so there's nothing specific about Russia
do you get the last question oh thank
you that's that's very nice so yeah
Frederic at the show burr get pushed
duck at Herman and I have a very general
question that's nice to kind of round up
this whole discussion a question about
democracy I would ask the panelists to
just kind of give us some intuitions or
or just kind of general impressions
about the relationship between
corruption and democracy it would seem
that the the case is that dr. Klein
brings up as cases that have kind of
dealt with the corruption issue and
managed to grow like Hong Kong Singapore
these are countries that looking you
know look quite appealing to a lot of
the post-soviet regimes especially the
ones in Central Asia they all want to be
Singapore especially Kazakhstan but
democracy is not democracy is not part
of that picture clearly and with
democracy I'm here referring to not the
whole package of democracy but really
kind of competitive politics multi-party
systems and kind of electoral
contestation and and whether or not we
should expect that to have any effects
on on corrupt based on the post-soviet
track record it seems like it's not a
clear it's not clear that that that more
democracy would and more competition
would lead to less corruption you know
Ukraine Kyrgyzstan nah nah not a lot of
good reforms in terms of corruption
after after the democratic revolution is
in the in the colored wave so so just
some general thoughts
that would be appreciated things
uncommon and that may not be really
quite what you're expecting but it's
been a lot of time talking with business
people and bankers about corporate
culture sort of rules of the game and
trying to help them understand I think a
really big difference between how how we
observe business rules in Western Europe
in the u.s. is that we accept as members
of those societies that those are rules
that as members of society we might not
like the rules but they are the rules of
the game and we sort of internalize them
and the people that I work with often
don't appreciate that we've actually
internalized then they see them in the
old sort of Soviet way of you know I
didn't buy into these rules they were
imposed on me they don't make any sense
and so my objective is to figure out a
way to get around them and so to me um
just to answer your question I think
that what it it sounds a little bit
naive but I think there is some truth to
the fact that in a democracy you feel
like you are part of the rules and
therefore you follow them in systems
where you don't feel like you're part of
the rules you know why would you bother
it's a form of revenge not to follow
them
okay hi I'm Elise Giuliano and I teach
here politics I don't I haven't spent a
lot of time talking thinking about
corruption but this is a really
interesting discussion and I like that
mr. Klein you keep emphasizing the
stability of the system but the
discussion today has pointed to many
possible factors that could lead to
change from norms or a sense of outrage
or morality to of course other elites
that want to get in on the action to
shock to the system so I was just
reading this article in The New York
Times the other day about Italy which
would seem to fall to the category of
very stable corrupt system but it was
about the EU in Italy so I just wanted
to ask if you you know have observed how
some states have responded to the or how
corruption has evolved in response to
making off with EU funds it was about
this this huge these different
localities or cities in in Italy that
have used EU funds to not build large
highways over long periods of time so I
thought it was a story I've actually
wondered why you know why is this making
the news or why is this is it because
the impetus for the investigation is
coming from the EU or is it because the
the egregious nest they'll degree of
venality of the local officials and the
local builders and extraction so what's
at play at making you know some
sometimes investigations move forward in
you know systems that are known to be
very corrupt and I was just wondering if
that would be sort of similar to the way
you talked about American corporations
coming in as an outsider and bringing in
maybe expectations and norms or just a
degree of oversight that could lead to a
change toward the decrease of corruption
I also say something about the previous
question just on the previous question
at the moment I said there are two big
models that I would think are out there
about democracy and efficiency or that
may be one way of framing it is it that
a lot of the successful states have been
authoritarian not all of them
some may have been democratic then there
is a bunch of democratic states in Latin
America India may be where you could
argue that maybe the future holds sort
of populist clientelism in store where
democracy gives the right to relatively
poor people to block progress so the
elites the rising middle classes aren't
strong enough and so on not arguing as
democracy here so but that may be the
outcome in this cases so this is the
debate Fukuyama versus are some aluminum
and we'll see how it turns out at the
end of the day again in a Darwinian view
of the world will countries that somehow
make it to both riches and democracy do
better than the ones that make it only
to the riches without that that goes
back to the fundamental thing what helps
the forces of creative destruction and
it seems to me that from a purely
economic efficiency point of view
democrasy could be a good thing because
it allows new entry it has a maximun
mechanism for exit oh and in the process
a way of making that legitimate which is
gales point in many in many ways so in
some sense democracy is the political
equivalent of competition in the market
not a new point but it's an economic
efficiency point and so you might think
that at the end of the day Fukuyama will
be right the end of history will have
both capitalism and democracy
notwithstanding the financial crisis but
at least concern I really don't know but
I would just have thought that anybody
who goes to Italy going on vacation to
Sardinia or going to Sicily etc oh my
god
no what has been done with all this EU
money and that the you may have some
influence but Sicily could look so much
nicer than it does now or Sardinia for
that matter when you look at these ruins
that have been built with EU money so
I'm not sure that how much the EU has
really achieved and when when you that's
just purely a question mark is not that
I have
view on us or when you hear now the
stories about the target and mafias
moving to the north and Italy that goes
exactly counter to the idea that the EU
has held the thing in check so federico
VAR AC who was a gambe de student and a
former postdoc here has this really nice
book called mobs on the move I think and
it looks at different attempts of mafias
to transplant themselves so the southern
Italy mob going to the north Russian
mafia trying to transplant itself in
Italy and and Hungary and also Italian
mafia you know transplanting itself in
the US but also failing to do so in
Latin America and a lot of he breaks it
down to these really transactions where
local knowledge is really key and he has
these great telephone conversations that
he was able to get from the judge
Falcone Falcone investigation of these
mobsters where he looks at the networks
of the the the mafias and they're very
interesting because the networks are
basically there's two nodes that talk to
each other and then there's everybody
else that talks to one of those two
nodes right so they keep the information
really really tight and then eventually
one of these guys kills the other so it
shows like we we sometimes have this
image of these kind of mafia or these
kind of network relations as if you know
they're really powerful and you know
they should be even easy to transplant
but you know it's often hard because
they rely on trust they rely on
information it's very hard to get
real accurate information about who's
cheating and who's not
so was this hard for the EU to figure
out precisely who's you know stolen what
where what and what they could actually
show but it's also hard for the Mafia's
to to you know expand their reach for a
lot of the same reasons great well
please join me in thanking the panel
[Applause]